after causing a huge controversy United
Airlines now says it will allow any
paying passenger to wear leggings
[Applause]
leggings so good news my dad can fly out
for Easter after all yeah
baseball season starting up next week
you excited
yeah yeah I couldn't hear what you said
it just was random and loud I couldn't
jump in joy I think he shouted out the
name of his team but I'll never know
president Trump has turned down a chance
to throw out the first pitch an opening
day for the Washington Nationals yeah
however Trump said he'll reconsider if
he can also throw out all the players
from other countries speaking the
Trump's I've anka Trump revealed that
she is planning to take a coding class
this summer with her five-year-old
daughter yeah
then this fall the five-year-old will
begin working at the White House is that
why not
behavioral scientists report that the
human brain is hardwired to gossip those
same scientists also reported that
Shelley is like such a [ __ ]
keep stroking yeah Apple Apple is
reportedly considering a device to put
in women's bodies that tracks their
menstrual cycles yeah yeah it's part of
Apple's new slogan think creepy it's
quite clear there's a new trend of rehab
clinics helping people get off meth by
letting them smoke pot yeah in other
words they're taking people from Florida
and turning them into people from
Colorado
[Applause]
you